you have a problem that I said I always
say that Tom taught me how to be a
person because he kind of taught me how
to behave
in the situation that's why I love her
because with kalila I can go we're gonna
go to this party and I know that she is
going to be able to handle herself
sometimes she doesn't want to go well I
never want to go but I also will show up
yeah this thing about showing up places
empty-handed yeah I culturally like
that's not allowed for being even very
like a Filipino and stuff like you just
gotta bring your offering and he's like
no we can show I haven't seen my friend
he hadn't seen his family and like gone
together in 15 years for Thanksgiving
was like you're gonna walk through that
door with nothing in your hand because
there's a part of me and they're so so
gross this is the grossest thing I've
ever said all right cool but um I told
her I go just probably showing that he
says his presence alone is a gift I
agree because I know that they don't
think this is I never show up ever right
just by me they don't know they don't
think I'm coming to San Diego like why
would he drive down right so I so in my
head I'm like if I walk in the dirt
gonna be oh my god he showed up that's
huge but then that's very um you know
[ __ ] know that's how I believe that
yeah [ __ ] that's what I believe Bryce
yeah yeah you know what you know what
you know [ __ ] yeah I drove down there
I don't need a you thank you how much do
you hate them your family like do you
aim them no I I have a love for them oh
really
because the thing is is that my cousins
even on both sides more on my mom's side
they're some of them are the creatures
of the night like I am like we're [ __ ]
off which is why we have trouble
deciding if we should procreate because
there's a lot of violence violence and
drug addiction on my side to violence I
mean like murders yeah and my mom turned
out to be the only
saying sibling out of 10 the only sane
one Wow so nine out of her ten are
really [ __ ] off and then this like
like Mike the cousin that we went to see
one of them her mom and my dad don't get
they're brother and sister and my dad
the last time they saw each other my dad
tried to kill her with a with a butter
knife yeah so he jumped out I remember
him jumping across the table trying to
cut her you know I was like I was maybe
12 well how much of this okay but your
your parents are immigrant - yeah my mom
yeah and then my dad side he worked for
the US government is like some agent of
the government so he's got some
murderous yeah my mom's is they're all
out of their [ __ ] minds or crazy
crazy but her dad is white yeah but my
dad is a white guy yes just crazier than
all but he was very calm and collected
and intelligent and the really kind man
right so I think that offset a lot of my
mom's insane genetics because most
serial killers are white males right
like you guys go bonkers because it's
creativity yeah I really do believe it's
creativity what what here's what it is
is ethnic people we like to do mass do
it at one time
ah-ha mass murder sure like chose some
way from Virginia Tech for instance okay
he shows up I'm not bragging about hey
to him I know but he does at one time
called the Asian work ethic you know
whatever you know but what but but why
people when they kill they get creative
like I want to see how long yeah right
they leave they drop hints see they're
the ones that like riddles they do the
riddles with the blood yeah and then
they also do creative things with the
body
Dean at gain he made lampshades out of
human skin right which that's creative
yeah
in fact Buffalo Bill oh yeah science
labs is drive from Ed Gein so they
inspire art love that movie called you
do I've seen that thing maybe 30 times a
now same here start to finish - if it's
on I have to watch it it's an evergreen
movie God my brother a couple of months
ago called me because I have he has my
iTunes account - because you know I
thought it was Silence of the Lambs
again wow what a great it really guys we
cuz it taps into like a woman's primal
fear you help me with this couch yeah
and she's like I don't want to be rude
and say no which is like every woman's
dilemma you know like I hate to be
perceived as unfriendly and then the
next thing you know you're gonna
[ __ ] read it the wrong way she
went but in all right yeah that's what
I'm saying you wouldn't do that you you
you yeah you're lifting right yeah I'm
lifting your couch I have to IV throw
and go backwards I have to go backwards
yeah I mean no you're going back deep
squad yeah I'm not strong do I look
strong yeah I'm not strong and she's a
politician's daughter yeah she should
know better
yeah here's another thing was it racist
[Laughter]
a weird casting right because she looked
completely different than fredericka
bumble yeah you know you've seen that
movie that many does so many times yeah
that's your name yeah I'm pretty good
Ben was the first girl who got killed
yeah I don't remember but I remember
this who doesn't
it's my favorite move would he pull you
know cuz when she's screaming yeah
screaming oh my god mimics her yeah yeah
I know and they're just fingernails in
the well oh yeah yeah
yah yah yah yah yes real Oh before we
get to that we have a wonderful sponsor
[Music]